we are shooting scene 106 and i knew
that from memory
the twilight saga eclipse needed to be
epic between its vampire battles and
emotional love triangle david slade had
to create the ultimate third part of the
twilight franchise it's such a different
experience
in this behind-the-scenes look at the
movie you'll see that the cast and
crew's love for stephanie meyer's story
and a whole lot of hard work is what
made it possible ready to see some
groundbreaking cgi and what taylor
lautner was really like off camera
don't hold back
not in my ages
while the characters grew and changed
throughout the twilight saga there was
one thing that stayed consistent vampire
speed one of the biggest challenges of
the movie has always been to capture
vampire speed getting human actors to
move at an inhuman pace not the easiest
the film crew had to come up with some
unique creations like the magic carpet
that they used during eclipse it was
basically a large treadmill that they'd
have the actors run on while speeding by
with the camera on another truck as long
as you're not seeing their feet it feels
like they're actually going very fast
they'd also have another version of the
carpet that they'd use in the studio for
scenes that required green screen the
cast got a little competitive with it
and even challenged one another on who
could run on the carpet's fastest level
i beat everyone well the magic carpet
was kind of magic there were just some
vampire shots that couldn't be done
without the help of computers like this
victoria moment that required them to
construct the entire scene digitally
after filming with her stunt double in
the studio where they had to create
custom green screen platforms to imitate
the jumping
she's close the vampire speed wasn't the
only road bump they had to overcome
filming on vancouver mountains wasn't
ideal for the cast and crew of eclipse
because the fall weather didn't offer
them the snow they needed and fake snow
was out of the question in public areas
instead the set director got creative we
built the entire mountaintop on the
stage and dressed it with the snow that
we would need for the sequence it took a
crew of about 50 people to go through
these vigorous steps to bring stephanie
meyer and director david slade's vision
to life the set was surrounded by green
screen and gave them the freedom to film
the bone chilling final battle with
victoria and jacob and edward's
emotional heart to heart in the tent if
she chooses me would you try to kill me
that's an intriguing idea
in the end it was the right choice not
only visually but because they were able
to spend as much time as they needed in
the studio whereas on location they
would have been constrained by time and
we could spend three weeks shooting the
final conflict which required extensive
amount of stunt work and wire work the
werewolves in eclipse may have looked
epic on screen but behind the scenes not
so much they used plastic wolves
werewolf-shaped punching bags for the
fight scenes and taylor lautner even
stepped in as a stand-in for the more
emotional scenes oh there's taylor hey
this is taylor how you doing
but the hard work was actually adding
the werewolves in during post-production
we pushed a lot of our technology
further than we've ever pushed it on
eclipse they added more detail to the
wolves in their fur and even their
muscles than they had in the previous
films when it came to filming each
location needed to be scanned and
created as a digital 3d model to
integrate the wolves in their scenes
seamlessly i'll strategically shoot
points on this hill right here and i'll
use those points so that we can build a
3d model of it later so that our wolves
have something to stand on they came a
long way from using real wolves in the
first film i've decided to throw a party
at your place i've never seen your house
no one's ever seen their house moving
filming locations from portland to
vancouver after the first twilight film
got even more complicated in eclipse
when the crew realized that they'd be
needing the cullen house a whole lot
more naturally they came up with a
solution we knew that we couldn't
consolidate everything into one room and
cheetah like we did on new moon so we
made the decision to build the structure
yep they built the entire interior and
exterior cullen house that we see on
screen during eclipse right down to the
forest surrounding it they filled the
exterior of the house with fake trees
rocks and realistic canvases my name's
xavier i play riley in eclipse david
slade knew that telling riley's story
properly was important to tie the film
all together but with the books being
from bella's point of view they didn't
have much information on riley and had
to bring in the expert stephanie meyer
there was a lot of confusion as to what
was going on off screen and i had some
stuff written up for riley so we went
through that once his story was
established they set off to their
locations with a lot of rain machines
xavier was a trooper and shot in a
wetsuit for hours to keep warm while
doing a lot of the wire work himself
old wolf coming up run
we all know while watching a movie that
everything is not what it seems but
knowing and actually seeing the
behind-the-scenes footage is a whole
different story during the scene where
jacob carries bella through the forest
took a lot of prep work i literally went
and got my rear end molded to make this
day easier on taylor but their plans
involving a super innovative rig and
molded seat didn't go as planned the
idea was for taylor to just support
kristen's weight while walking with her
in the rig but they just couldn't get it
to look realistic on camera or like
taylor can you just carry kristen for
the day so poor taylor spent hours
walking back and forth carrying kristen
while it was a piece of cake for him in
the beginning by the end of the day he
was completely broken by the end of the
day my arms are just like shaking so bad
speaking of onset workouts the cullens
actors went through some intense
training for their roles as vampires
they put like a piece of cheese up there
and then we all run
try to get cheese
before filming even began they attended
group workout sessions to get in shape
and develop their fighting techniques
welcome to our vampire bat cave this is
where all the booty kicking goes down it
was important to david that the cullens
each had their own style of fighting
that represented their background while
also taking into consideration the moves
jasper would be showing them from his
war days one more thing
never turn your back on your enemy
for example alice is more agile and
light on her feet while emmett is all
about his size and strength believe it
or not the actors performed a lot of
their own stunts adding to the realism
of it all
would you do me the extraordinary honor
of marrying me
the eclipse team had the tough task of
bringing to life bella's engagement ring
it took them four different attempts and
in the end they only achieved the level
of perfection they needed by asking for
help from stephanie what we ended up
doing is having a conversation with
stephanie meyer who then drew us a
little sketch of the ring that they
ended up finally building the ring is 14
karat white gold and kristen ended up
being the lucky one who got to take the
ring home as a memento of her time on
set
i'm gonna need that ring
we can't talk about bella and edward's
engagement without discussing their
meadow and how it came to be david
recognized that this was one of the most
important locations in bedward's story
and needed to make everything perfect
this meant creating an idealistic place
that was cinematically beautiful it's
the only piece of sanctuary that edward
and bella have to bring his vision to
life they hand planted thousands of
flowers and mixed with kristen and
edward's chemistry the scene was
breathtaking we have established
dynamics that nobody can mess with
before bringing these beautiful scenes
like the meadow to life they had to deal
with one small tiny matter kristen's
hair kristen had cut her hair for her
role in the film the runaways the
twilight filmmakers were completely
against the notion and even offered
kristen what she called many ridiculous
things to not cut her hair but she had
confidence in the wig department
confidence that may have been misplaced
i just thought we'd have a better wig
and it's okay her wig in eclipse wasn't
the greatest and caused a lot of issues
in the editing room that resulted in
reshoots there were even reports that
because of the wig kristen was involved
in some heated talks while filming the
tent scene and stephanie meyer herself
even confirmed the wig troubles and it's
something that they've had to deal with
they were able to fix the wig but fans
still had their issues with it when the
film was released
we're throwing grapes into taylor's
mouth the cast and crew weren't always
dealing with an issue or two some days
on set were just about having some fun
or for taylor good old healthy
competition when he was bored in between
takes he would gather his own tiny film
crew with an assistant and create
challenges for himself involving grapes
and footballs he may just be the
greatest grape catcher hollywood has
ever seen are you watching that
what would a movie set be without some
great outtakes including these hilarious
bloopers
with a cast that was spending every day
for months with one another we can only
just imagine how many funny moments took
place on camera and off where could she
be
oh there she is
according to kristen there were a lot of
these moments especially between her and
robert pattinson me and rob laugh more
in the really serious scenes and like
much much less in the scenes that's
supposed to be light and funny they just
couldn't keep it together and ruined
multiple takes while working with one
another it's ironic to think about how
robb went from almost being fired on the
first twilight film because of his
seriousness to him not being able to
stop laughing while filming eclipse i
came back i came back after lunch was
like hi i want to keep my job
one thing is for sure robsten's
chemistry was undeniable it's not just
about me no
eclipse is the turning point in the
twilight saga for the audience and bella
swan herself from groundbreaking cgi to
hilarious bloopers every aspect came
together to create one of the best films
in the franchise what behind the scenes
moment was your favorite let us know in
the comment section below thanks for
watching